he's out of time everything Carter went
off the rails and so we need you to come
back cuz everyone kept asking me where
the Avengers are no I don't know what
the sides are that's a welcome back
everyone it's Charlie they just released
spider-man far from home on digital
today so we have a much better look at
the post-credits scenes and all the
stuff that they're teasing for
spider-man 3 in Marvel phase 4 well do a
new giveaway 4 copies of the movie all
you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and leave your best
spider-man 3 theory on the video so
we'll talk about the stuff that they
were clearly trying to set up with these
post-credit scenes and then some of the
other stuff that they talked about on
the bonus features and now what's gonna
be different about that because
spider-man 3 will be a pure Sony film
without a whole lot of MCU stuff in it
there are some bonus features that are a
little bit awkward now when you watch
them on this home video release where
they talk about spider-man's role in
Marvel phase 4 and how he's growing into
one of the leaders of the MCU it's a
good reminder that the people on the
ground that actually are responsible for
making these movies don't have anything
to do with negotiating those huge
contracts in the boardrooms but you
start with a deleted scene of Peter
walking out of the airport Aunt May
greets him tries to pick him up they
make the joke about the luggage being
blown up remember that was the luggage
that belonged to Uncle Ben so it's kind
of a sad moment I'm sure at some point
during the next two spider-man films
that Sony announced they're making
spider-man 3 spider-man for it they will
reference Uncle Ben at some point in a
more meaningful way but in the deleted
scene Aunt May actually asks Peter about
the stark tech glasses Peters like what
do you think of these and she's like you
know that doesn't really look that great
on you which is just a joke about
Mysterio earlier in the movie trying to
get the glasses from him telling him
that they look stupid on him he tells
her that they used to belong to Iron Man
she feels kind of bad for telling him
that they don't look so great on him and
says you'll grow into them so it's just
a reference that he'll continue to be
using those glasses obviously that's
gonna change now because they're leaning
away from Marvel Cinematic Universe
references with spider-man 3 because of
this split so he'll still have the
glasses but they probably won't
reference them he'll probably just put
them on a shelf somewhere in the
background if they appear at all during
spider-man 3 but then after he addresses
Aunt May
Epis relationship r.i.p to their
relationship because of all the
characters that they can bring in to
spider-man 3 through the Sony deal happy
is not one of them because technically
he originated in an MCU movie not in the
Sony spider-man movies there was another
question about that which actors can
they use which actors can they not use
anybody that originated in spider-man
homecoming all the classmates those
people they can come back for spider-man
3 spider-man for any movies that Sony
wants to make on their own spider-man
swings out to meet his date with MJ he
pulls at his phone and starts taking
selfies just like Marvel's spider-man
game that's a reference to the actual
game but as he's swinging through
Midtown he actually swings and runs
across the Osborn penthouse from the Sam
Raimi spider-man films no idea if
they're gonna bring Norman Osborn into
the trilogy even faster now because it
seems like they're spinning up for
sinister six and they want that spin-off
franchise that they did not get to do
during the Andrew Garfield amazing
spider-man era in real life that
two-door complex could actually be found
near the United Nations between forty
forty third first and second avenues he
glides through the newly redesigned
Avengers Tower still haven't found out
who bought that originally I think most
of us thought that it was going to turn
into the new Baxter building in the home
of the Fantastic Four because Kevin
Feige he's been hyping them up so much
in there's another fantastic for Easter
Egg within moments of this scene but
because of the Marvel Sony split I
wouldn't be surprised if they turned
this into Oscorp now which would also be
a really good themed attic Easter Egg
where you have Norman Osborn trying to
forcibly take the legacy of Tony Stark
on himself
I am the new leader of this giant
universe but because it's Sony it's
easier for them to use that because they
can't really use any other characters
from Marvel he swings down on the pole
and you see the signs in the background
of the construction that's also adjacent
to the New Avengers Tower it has the
numbers one two three four with arrows
pointing to a question mark for Marvel
phase four also fantastic for Easter Egg
but also this we can't wait to show you
what comes next
so that's bitter there Marvel phase four
teaser we can't wait to show you all the
stuff because this actually dropped
before the big Marvel phase for Comic
Con panel so when we were watching this
in the theater we had no idea officially
what they were going to be doing during
Marvel phase four but the place where
they're standing here on the corner east
41st
in library way is just a couple blocks
away from where the Baxter building is
in the comics so we're right around the
corner from quote-unquote fantastic for
Kevin Feige revealed that they're
developing a Fantastic Four movie at
Comic Con part of the reason why we
probably don't see any literal like very
obvious Fantastic Four references is
because this is a Sony spider-man movie
that they made in combination with
Marvel and they want to keep a lot of
that to themselves he swings with MJ all
the way to Penn Station she screams and
says they're never doing that again then
as he gets ready to leave the news
broadcast starts and the station plays
the video that Mysterio sent them
through his underling who may or may not
take the mantle of Mysterio in future
movies there are a lot of theories about
how Mysterio could have survived that
bridge fight I'll talk about that in a
second he cleverly pins the whole thing
on spider-man really anybody with
Premiere Pro or any basic editing tools
could put together a video like that an
arat that's part of Mysterio's joke is
that it's such a basic turn but
everybody believes it because it's being
aired on news people just automatically
believe everything that they see on the
news we get r.j. jonah Jameson cameo Amy
Pascal also recently revealed that part
of the reason for bringing him back was
to tie this to the earlier Sam Raimi
spider-man films they didn't really get
to Jay jonah Jameson during Andrew
Garfield era but there were all kinds of
viral teasers for the Daily Bugle so
they had intended to introduce him at
some point during that franchise
she wasn't really clear when she said
how much they wanted to tie these new
Tom Hollands spider-man films to the
Tobey Maguire films like are you gonna
bring him back for a cameo or do you
just want this to be a thematic
connection you can theory craft about
that there's been talk about live-action
spider-man into the spider-verse
and they talked about bringing Tobey
Maguire and Andrew Garfield back for the
animated spider-man into the spider
verse so at some point eventually you
will see some version of those older
Spider Men come back in some capacity
whether it be cameo or bigger roles then
you get the Nick Fury post-credit scene
and this is an even bigger Marvel phase
4 teaser first stuff is coming we hit
the Fantastic Four Silver Surfer all the
big cosmic stuff that's coming up
Talos and his wife changed back they
make jokes about how they completely
botched up the very simple tasks that
Nick Fury gave them we were just
supposed to give the glasses to the kid
in that was it they also drop an Easter
Egg about
sleeper cells which is a very big twist
on a secret invasion trope the whole
idea with comic-book civil war is that
it was the scrolls that tried to take
over planet Earth after Marvel's civil
war tour everyone apart and left earth
in a very weakened state ripe for
takeover that's what the scrolls took
advantage of in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the big twist is is that most
of the scrolls are actually good people
and because this is all HD nice and
shiny you can clearly see that everybody
that's working with Nick Fury on this
sword Space Station from the comics in
Earth's orbit is a scroll the joke about
Nick Fury being that he's supposed to be
on a mission on the sword Space Station
for some big Marvel phase for Marvel
phase 5 cosmic stuff but at the moment
that he calls them he's actually just
chilling out on a quote-unquote Tahiti
simulation beach just like agents of
shield Tahiti is a wonderful place when
he sits up to walk off and go find his
shoes you look off to the side on the
panel there you can see some of these
shapes forming a four in the background
another Fantastic Four Easter Egg you
look over here in the background and you
can actually see some of the outside of
the space station it actually looks like
a giant sword that's one of the reasons
why they call it sword but it's also an
acronym just like shield is an acronym
for sentient world observation in
response Department it's basically a
space-based version of shield for cosmic
threats that are trying to attack earth
from outside Marvel just announced that
they're doing a Silver Surfer movie we
kind of knew that they would do that
eventually but they've already announced
Fantastic Four Silver Surfer or somebody
that comes from the Fantastic Four
comics so that makes sense that you
would do Fantastic Four before you do
Silver Surfer Galactus stuff this is all
setting up big Avengers 5 level stuff
but Kevin Feige did reveal that there
will not be an Avengers movie during
Marvel phase 4 not til Marvel phase 5
just because they're setting up so many
new characters during phase 4 here's the
thing though because of the Sony
spider-man split there's a whole lot of
MCU stuff that they were setting up for
spider-man that they'll have to lean
away from in a whole lot of MCU stuff
they were setting up for spider-man that
the MCU will have to lean away from for
a little while remember Avengers 5 isn't
happening for a long time they have
plenty of time to work out a new deal to
get spider-man back in the MCU before
that happens
that's why spider-man 3 will probably
lean into Kraven the hunters
spider-man hunted spider-man homeless
however you want to think about him on
the run John wick 3style with everybody
that Sony wants to throw at him coming
after him he's already making his new
suits he'll have to make a new suit
because Sony will want to get him out of
the MCU versions of the suits they'll
probably find some way to destroy the
new black and red suit that he just
built for himself and even though
technically they do have rights to use
the iron spider suit they will probably
take that away from him too just to lean
away from Iron Man references in Easter
eggs because they can't reference
anymore iron man stuff so a lot of the
Iron Man Easter eggs and the stuff that
he built on won't really make sense if
you can't mention Iron Man so don't be
surprised if they start leaning into
sinister six and venom faster than they
originally would have because originally
the intention was for Kevin Feige to
produce spider-man three in spider-man 4
just like he did the first two films
then after that you would ply start to
see some of the crazier stuff that the
Sony people have talked about like
live-action spider-man into the spider
verse big infinity war level events
centered around the spider-man character
but through Sony instead of through
Marvel like I said there's a lot of
Fantastic Four stuff being teased in
this they just announced the Silver
Surfer movie I'll do a video for that
next that should post later today but if
there any Easter eggs in the
post-credits scene that I didn't mention
that you guys spotted write them below
in the comments while you wait for
everything click here for that brand-new
deleted scene of them dropping
spider-man and x-men crossover back
during Iron Man 1 and phase 1 and click
here for my video about Quicksilver
coming back during Doctor Strange -
thank you so much for watching everybody
staying awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]
you